all right we are now live for something
new that i decided to start doing
and that is these uh
we'll do them as monthly for the time
being maybe we'll we'll start doing more
of them later on if there's sufficient
demand sessions on basics of stoic
philosophy
and practice and i think this can be
quite helpful there's a lot of let's
call them
misunderstandings of what it is that
stoicism
teaches holds
offers to us and i think that a lot of
this is caused by
you know people relying on sound bite
stuff so what i'm going to offer here
is a
not complete deep dive but at least some
well-informed discussion about what the
stoics meant by
the virtues and we'll do one of these
each month if it's uh popular enough
maybe we'll do them every two weeks or
every week or something like that so
this is the first one and
welcome everybody to it i hope that you
enjoy it and get something out of it i'm
going to talk for maybe 15 to 20 minutes
or so
and you know you can leave comments
questions in the chat and i will be
spending a good bit of time answering
and addressing those once i get through
what it is that i'm going to talk about
and i suspect that
some of them some of the questions or
comments that people might leave
especially about the virtues
will
be answered in the course of the
discussion so
let's
start with the actual
discussion of it so stoicism and the
four virtues that's that's our topic for
the day
there's a sort of common statement that
we see
being made a lot that stoicism holds
that virtue is the only good
vice the only bad or evil strictly
speaking that's not completely true and
that can be a little bit misleading
unless we understand what the stoics
mean by virtue
and vice
the virtues are absolutely essential to
stoicism but they they do recognize that
there are some other good things besides
simply
virtue and and you know for example
friendship is is a good thing now um
i think that on this topic
there is absolutely no substitute for
going back to the classic stoic texts
and thinkers and i mean the good news is
almost all of these are available
for free you can find them
online and you know we ought to spend
time
reading them in thoughtful rational
wise ways and there's several key issues
with understanding the range of stoic
perspectives on virtues and vices i'm
just going to approach one of them
here thematically so and here's here's
the central question what are the
virtues that the stoics recognize why
these four virtues and what are the four
virtues we're talking about they're
often called the cardinal virtues wisdom
or prudence justice courage sometimes
called bravery temperance sometimes
called moderation self-control these
four virtues wisdom justice courage
temperance are acknowledged as the
cardinal virtues and i should point out
this is not a idea that's coming from
the stoics this is an idea that's
already out there and being discussed by
a number of different philosophical
schools remember too that zeno himself
was a synthesizer he didn't just study
with krates the cynic he also studied
with um
the uh you know the platonist academy he
studied with the mergarian school
so
i see people are asking some some
questions try to make the questions
relevant to what we're talking about
here this is not an ama this is directly
focused on on stoicism so coming back to
the cardinal virtues plato talks about
the cardinal virtues if any of you have
ever read the republic and you got to
book four
you know that um you know those four
virtues were talked about there
also it's discussed in the symposium um
you know if you look at the protagoras
there's five virtues being discussed but
plato tends to lump piety under justice
in an interesting way in the amino
magneminity or great souledness gets
discussed
the later platonists they were pretty
clear that there were there were four
basic virtues that they were interested
in
the epicureans also
reference these four virtues and you
might be very very surprised if you've
gotten sort of you know epicureans are
are bad stoics are a good sort of take
that a lot of people
have
um as as uh you know reading from say
epictetus or you know popular texts on
stoicism seneca actually talks a lot
about the epicureans because he's
writing to an epicurean in the you know
letters on ethics of course right
lucillus is influenced by the epicureans
and so seneca is saying hey we can we
can draw some good stuff from them um
we're going to find other thinkers going
on into the christian middle ages who
are referencing these cardinal virtues
it's really a commonplace of philosophy
the one major school
in ancient times that you can say didn't
really
discuss the four cardinal virtues as
such and make that central to their
approach would be of course the
aristotelians who recognized a number of
other virtues as well but those could be
rolled under the cardinal virtues as the
stoics do and as other people do
i would say it's less important that we
focus on the origination of the idea and
what we want to do
is think about what do these different
schools make of it so the platonists do
not make the same thing
of the virtues as the stoics do the
epicureans as well the christians that
are considering them are going to add
their own twists to it so we want to
focus on the stoics right
and
where do we go for understanding the
cardinal virtues in the stoics
um
marcus aurelius who's very popular when
people first get into stoicism and i
think you know some people unfortunately
remain content with only reading marcus
um
they you know he doesn't he he
references the virtues a lot he doesn't
go into any sort of systematic
discussion of them
epictetus
i'm a big fan of epictetus he's probably
my favorite stoic but he's not the place
to go to understand the virtues as such
because he's working with other ethical
concepts that you could say implicitly
include the virtues but he's not doing a
systematic exposition of the virtues
sonia's rufus epictetus teacher
had a good bit of useful things to say
about virtues and vices in particular in
his lectures
number three number four
uh and then six through eight so he
gives us some you know some useful stuff
but it's it's not going into great depth
and unfortunately we don't have
a lot of what uh mussonius probably
wrote
so where should we go then well
as i mentioned
seneca right the the stoic who we have
the most of um you're going to find in
his treaty seas and in his letters he is
going to tell us a lot about the
virtues so there's some systematic
sometimes even comprehensive discussion
of virtues and vices in his letters and
treatises and we we also really need to
look at the two summaries of stoic
doctrine that we we have so one of these
is found in diogenes laertes lives of
the philosophers and specifically in
book seven
in the life of xeno diogenes says well
since i've told you about this guy xeno
who is the originator of stoicism
somebody asked a question about that
who's the first stoic well uh zeno right
uh that's why diogenes begins with him
he then says i'm going to summarize what
the stoics actually believe and so he
provides us with a a useful summary
there another really helpful work is
aries didymus's uh epitome of stoic
ethics sometimes uh people who are you
know um citing this we'll call it
stobayus that's not actually the right
way to talk about it johannes delbayes
wrote this this big compendium that
included
a whole bunch of things and
among them uh arius ditimus's epitome of
stoic ethics and his epitome of
aristotelian ethics and so um you know
we we go into those
and then another really invaluable
source is cicero if you're studying
stoicism and you're not reading cicero
because you've heard well cicero isn't a
stoic you're screwing yourself over
because a lot of what we know about
stoicism you know apart from the late
period where we have you know seneca and
epictetus and marcus aurelius and
musonius and
a few other people
much of it is coming from cicero so you
really want to read him and if you only
read one book on stoics and the virtues
it is his book on duties where he says
i'm going to present the stoic position
right
so
he's going to be quite important and i'm
going to reference all these these
people except for marcus uh and musonius
uh as we go through so one of the
guiding questions that we can ask that
always comes up over and over and over
and over again when it comes to stoics
and the virtues is
why do the stoics only talk about these
four virtues doesn't that leave a lot of
stuff out isn't that you know
isn't that problematic and the answer
as it so often is in philosophy is
yes and no
right we don't want to take a
knee-jerk immediate reaction you know if
you look at things carefully you find
out that matters are usually a lot more
complicated than they originally
seem
so
there's a couple things that we can say
here
are the stoics leaving anything out and
we can say yes they they are in fact
leaving some things out that other
people call virtues and why are the
stoics leaving them out they don't think
they're virtues so you know for example
the aristotelians they have this virtue
that they call proutase which means good
temper mildness gentleness there's a lot
of translations and it has to do with
feeling anger and acting on anger in the
right way towards the right people to
the right degree you know all those
sorts of things that if you know about
aristotelian ethics you're already
probably quite familiar with the you
know the virtuous mean the stoics say
that uh there is no virtuous meaning
with respect to anger anger is bad so
there's no virtue
that he has to do at the right amount um
christians bringing in the theological
virtues like faith and hope and charity
as well as other things considered
virtuous like you know fear of god which
is coming from the you know hebrew
scriptures and stuff like that those can
be considered virtues um you know and
humilities is another great example one
you know humilius men's or humilitas in
the latin literature
those are not things that the stoics see
as
virtuous right
and and you know could they open up to
that well when it comes to faith feed
ace you're going to notice that that
actually does get discussed as a virtue
by both seneca and cicero but they don't
mean the same thing that christians mean
by it right
um we could even look at like you know
more contemporary discussions of virtues
you know one one prime example of
something that a stoic would not go
along with you know ein rand in her
objectivist ethics she has a whole bunch
of things she calls virtues the stoics
would say
yeah those aren't virtues at all you
know they're they're on the wrong base
so there's that's the um is there
something being left out yes there is
something being left outside
but then you can say okay i get that
there seem to be a lot of legitimate
virtues that ought to be recognized by
stoics but aren't being
aren't being put in this list of four so
the most common objection that i see is
what about kindness isn't kindness a
virtue being nice to other people
benevolence why don't the stoics
acknowledge this
and if you think about the
caricature of what stoics are like you
know hands off uh stick to themselves
you know uncommitted detached from
things you know cold and rule-bound um
well you know that could feed into that
but that's if you actually read stoic
literature that is not what stoics are
like at all you know read seneca and
you'll see him talking about you know
friendship and the warmness and you know
uh fellow feeling read marcus and he
says love other people right so clearly
there's something there and you can say
well why why aren't they talking about
it it's not in prudence it's not
injustice it's not in courage it's not
in temperance and the answer is
actually it is
injustice the stoic conception of
justice
includes benevolence or kindness or
generosity
cicero will actually use
all three of terms that correspond to
all three of those words telling us
about the other half of justice
so
we can ask our question well why don't
people know about this and this is where
reading actual stoic texts
would help you out right you're going to
hear me say this over and over and over
again there is no substitute for
actually reading and re-reading uh not
only with the stoics but with any
philosophy if you want to talk about you
know somebody brought up spinoza
don't rely on you know encyclopedia
entries or glosses or stuff like that
you gotta read the actual text right if
you wanna talk about hegel you gotta
read the actual text and it's probably
gonna require reading and re-reading so
let's let's think about what's included
in these these virtues um
later on in other sessions we'll go into
you know other topics having to deal
with the virtues like them being kind of
like off on switches and we'll do deeper
dives on each of these four virtues but
we're already getting
close to the end of the time i allotted
myself so i do want to try to get
through this we might actually go a
little bit over so
why these four virtues in particular
so they do not relate to the platonic
tripartite soul the stoics have a
different anthropology they're not
getting it in the same way that plato is
they're doing something different with
this
each virtue has its own
you could say function for the human
being a determinate kind of goodness
that we human beings need that develops
out of and develops our distinctively
human nature so i've got a few passages
from some of the people i've mentioned
that i think are you know helpful
starting points these are not to be
understood as like the be all and end
all on the virtues but
cicero in on duties book one
says that all that is morally right
arises from one of four sources it is
concerned either
with the full perception and
intelligent development of the true so
that's wisdom right
or with the conservation of organized
society rendering to every person
they're due and the faithful discharge
of obligations assumed that's justice
with the greatness and strength of a
noble and invincible spirit that's
courage which includes magnaminity
and uh with the orderliness and
moderation of everything that is said
and done wherein we're in consists
temperance and self-control
temperance right so cicero thinks that
these stem from our very human nature
what it is that makes us distinctively
human and the kind of animal that we are
rational and social animals
in letter 120 i noticed somebody was
asking like what letters to look at for
seneca
well letter 120 is a really important
one he tells us the desires had to be
reigned in
right temperance fear to be suppressed
okay courage proper actions to be
arranged
that's wisdom debts to be paid therefore
we included self-restraint bravery
prudence and justice assigning to each
quality its special function
arius didymus
who you notice there's different
translations of these greek terms and
latin terms says um
and this is in section 5b2
intelligence or wisdom deals with
appropriate acts or duties
self-restraint deals with a person's
impulses bravery deals with acts of
endurance justice deals with the
apportioning of what is due now this is
a treatment of the virtues that is going
to be
very influential you'll notice that a
lot of medieval christian thinkers like
for example thomas aquinas who are not
stoics
will use this kind of approach which
they're taking from seneca or from
cicero because they had access to those
texts
and they thought that this was a good
summary of like the full scope of a
virtue the things that we we need
if we look at the actual virtues the
stoics think that the virtues
are sort of like big baskets or big
brackets that include a whole bunch of
parts you could say or aspects however
you want to think about them
so if we look at wisdom or intelligence
or prudence
arius didymus tells us that there's six
different sub-virtues and you know i'm
going to give you the greek terms and
then we'll talk about you know the
english translation which we could use
other words to translate and there are
some
glosses that are provided i'll just give
you one of these so for example
soundness of judgment is a knowledge of
what sort of things to do and how to do
them so we will act expediently so it's
an aspect of prudence or wisdom
so they mentioned eubolia soundness of
judgment diogenes liertes also mentions
that as part of wisdom
eu logista circumspection um being able
to you know
mark things off properly
um
shrewdness also mentioned by diogenes
liertes uh nunez literally like having a
having a brain sensibleness
uh eustochion soundness
ingenuity right and each of these is a
part or an aspect of wisdom diogenes
liertes adds sunasis
understanding right so we've got at
least seven different components of the
virtue
of wisdom or intelligence or prudence
each of which is its own
sub-virtue and there's a lot more if we
bring in seneca and cicero and people
like that
what about temperance really really
central virtue
um that uh arius talks about um
four different parts to this
eutaxia orderliness also mentioned by
diogenes in
section 126
cosmeotes propriety mentioned by
diogenes idomosune which is coming from
the word idos which means shame or
bashfulness modesty this is very
important and then an encrypted
self-control also mentioned by diogenes
so we've got at least four different
aspects of temperance being talked about
there
courage is a really interesting virtue
uh it includes a lot of stuff
so
arius talks about five different aspects
of this criteria perseverance is how we
often translate that
that's also mentioned by diogenes uh
thoroughly tastes intrepidness being
confident is another way of translating
that
megalopsy
meghala
this is a really really important thing
that aristotle considers to be a
separate virtue but the stoics place
under courage it means great solidness
it means rising above
it means you know not letting things
drag you down to the level of the
common
diogenesis also mentions this and cicero
makes a lot of this in his discussion of
courage he almost uses these as as
synonyms
um
stout heartedness you know being able to
to uh put up with the these sorts of
things and then finally
philoponian
philoponia rather
industriousness
applying yourself to your work is a kind
of courage for the stoics isn't that
interesting
diogenes laertes adds two other terms
here
epilaxia constancy
and utonia vigor constancy is also
another big theme for the stoics
constantia in latin
falls under courage and all of these
have to do not just like mastering fear
but with like sticking to what you need
to do right
cicero will also bring in control not
only of fear but of anger desire and a
few other emotions in his discussion of
courage then finally we get to justice
so
again arius divides up
um justice into four different kinds of
things eusebia piety right uh the proper
relation to the divine
uh chris
can be translated as kindness being you
being useful for other people
uh eu
comes from the word koinos you know the
the koinonia sharing
having community eu coinonia gets
translated i think this is a nice one
good fellowship and then finally
use uh
usonolexia fair dealing giving people
what they deserve what we typically
think of as justice right so you notice
that for arius
these other aspects of
justice that have to do with being good
to other people are really really
central cicero in on duties will say
this virtue that has to do with other
people
has to do with
two sides one we call justice eustitia
the other we have three different words
for
we can call it beneficence beneficentia
benignitas
being good to other people
and liberalitas which means generosity
towards other people that is just as
much a part of virtue as is fulfilling
contracts or you know apportioning
things rightly cicero also goes on to
tell us the foundation of justice is
good faith which is fides right remember
i said christianity has you know these
theological virtues well the ancients
also talked about fides
and it includes truth and fidelity to
promises veritas constantia right
i'm going to finish up here by talking
about another letter somebody asked you
know what letters to look at in seneca
so letter 88 this is another important
one where he's talking about the liberal
arts
and he says let's make a survey of the
virtues one by one
courage fortitudo in latin loyalty fides
self-control temprancia
kindness
humanitas
honesty simplicitas
temperance modestia
moderation translated by the you know
very close word moderation frugality
frugalitas
thrift parsimonia and now notice this
last one clemency
clemencia
these are all things that are not being
necessarily discussed by these other
authors what does this show us here's
where i'm going to wrap up and i'll
start answering some of these questions
the stoic conception of these four
cardinal virtues is quite complex and it
includes a lot of things and not every
stoic author or summarizer of stoic
doctrine has the same list
we should include
these with you know these various lists
within the scope of that as i've done
for example if you look up my my article
that i published in medium a while back
on what is what is actually courage for
the stoics we we do that we look at what
each of these people has to say about it
so we have to put together a composite
picture
this can only be done
if you're either actually reading stoic
text or you're relying on good faithful
discussions in in the present day or
previously of other people um
of stoic doctrines but you don't know
whether they're actually good unless you
read the texts so
uh you know i mentioned that i would
stress this at several points
that's probably stressed enough now
let's take a look at some of the
questions and comments that we have
um
all right so
mark said
you know the tripartite
division of soul is the stoic virtues so
i mentioned earlier
plato has a tripartite division of soul
into the you know the logical or
irrational part uh the thematic part a
middle part and then the appetites which
are multiple
and by the way it's not the same thing
as freud's tripartite division into id
ego superego a lot of people you know
like to blur those together the stoics
are doing something different in their
anthropology they think that we have
basically one part that does the
reasoning and that is also the part with
which we feel emotions and desires so
the virtues for the stoics are being
worked out on a different basis than we
find in in plato's republic uh book five
uh as is says what is the popular
alternative to stoicism uh there is no
popular alternative to stoicism either
you're actually like
practicing stoicism that's part of why
we have these things uh or you're not
and there's there's a lot of you could
say fake stoicisms and i i use that word
very deliberately you know there's what
we call broicism the emphasis on hyper
masculinity that is anti-stoic you know
if you actually look at what the stoics
say about courage these people who are
like taking cold showers and talking
about how tough they are and manliness
and stuff like that they're not stoics
remotely they're actually
contrary to what stoics teach or you
know the people who are all about life
hacks and stuff like that not a
substitute for stoicism and a lot of
those life hacks outside of a proper
context will actually screw you up and
get you stuck in bad habits the virtues
are dispositions by the way you develop
them by working on them if you develop
the wrong sort of habits
you're screwing yourself you know so i
wouldn't try to look for any sort of a
popular
alternative to stoicism unless you
you know want to go off base right
uh raptor as can you recommend specific
letters seneca works with it have the
most meat on the virtues i mentioned a
few of them there's there's a number of
other ones um i mean the easiest thing
to do is just get seneca and look in the
index when it comes to
virtues right
and you'll find a bunch of them um
there's there a lot of them are towards
the end of the letter
collection
uh one of them that i really really like
i think i you know um
there's one that has to do and i'm
blanking on the name with how we
how we came to see these things as
virtues and he talks about grasping them
by by seeing people who actually
exercise them to some degree
cicero also says a similar thing
somebody doesn't have to be perfect to
be
virtuous right no some of the stoics
think that you you you know if you've
got the virtue you've got the virtue
like 100
seneca and cicero are a little bit more
more you know realistic about that
um
all right so
warren asks thoughts on the connections
between stoicism and spinoza's ethics
and they're doing similar but different
things
spinoza is not a stoic uh neo-stoicism
was quite popular at the time
stoics thinks that we actually you know
do have a self we're not just a
mode of god or anything like that so
there's a huge difference there with
spinoza i also think spinoza did not do
himself any favors by presenting his
ethics in this more geometrical
he thinks that that's going to make it
easier to understand and it becomes very
difficult for a lot of people to
understand when you get to the later
books when he's talking about the
emotions seneca is definitely not a
stoic because the stoics think that
there are some good emotions
again you'll find these discussed for
example in cicero
and in you know
places in seneca
uh in in marcus aurelius and in these
you know summaries of stoic doctrine
they'll talk about the eu pathei right
spinoza doesn't really have anything
other than intellectual love of god all
the passions are bad for for you know
for us in in one way or another so you
know spinoza
there's some similarities there some big
differences
i mean you could say the same thing with
descartes you know
um gabriel on practicing virtues how do
you know which virtue is at play in any
given circumstance okay so that's a good
question
um what's being asked of us if we go
back to
these uh you know things that like
seneca and cicero and arius said so
think about cicero's on duties all that
is morally right
arises from some one of four sources
it's concerned with full perception and
intelligent development of the true is
that what you're working with well
wisdom right
conservation of organized society well
okay now we got justice right um
greatness and strength of a noble and
invincible spirit or you know for seneca
fear to be suppressed or
uh an acts of endurance there we got
bravery or courage right you see how
this works you again when you read the
texts
it really helps out with figuring out
which virtue we need at one point i'll
also mention that the stoics think that
the virtues interpenetrate and inform
each other so
you know courage is not courage when
wisdom or justice is lacking again to
talk about broessism these guys who are
like you know um i i'm i'm so tough and
stuff like that they're not stoic
because actual courage they don't have
it they have some some other thing
instead you know a lack of human
development that they're passing off as
courage and it's because it's not
informed by wisdom and and justice right
so
all right let's see what else we have
here um
sergio marcus aurelius talks about
kindness very much so and love and
affection so again the stoics are not
anti-emotional
they think that there are good emotions
that we we ought to be cultivating and
if you are a just person
you are going to be feeling those
emotions and they they may also require
you know for example um
courage
to love somebody who's you know
connected with you
it but who's kind of a an a-hole
that takes perseverance that's that's
part of courage right
uh you know to do what epictetus tells
you i meant i mentioned right epictetus
doesn't talk about virtue but it's
implicit in his ideas
in that passage where he says you get
you can pick things up by one handle or
another your brother is a prick to you
are you going to look at them as being a
prick and like respond to them
accordingly or are you going to say well
they're my brother i'm i can be a good
brother to them
that takes courage
right
moderation or temperance might come in
as well um you know that might inform
justice not eating like a pig and
consuming lots of resources so that you
can actually offer them to those who are
needy
moderation or temperance is going to
help you with that right
being in a good
relationship
where you can develop intimacy the
stoics thought that was quite important
it could be part of friendship with
sonius rufus actually says that within a
marriage it's not just about making
babies uh or sexual pleasure it's about
developing friendship um
not being able to you know as we say
keep it in your pants would be a big
impediment to that and so moderation
might might really help that out so the
virtues are are interconnected with each
other
um
all right so
nemanja says there's not many so many
letters from seneca why not read them
all yeah every i mean if you want to be
a stoic or you want to practice stoicism
sooner or later you you do need to read
through seneca's letter collection and
it's well worth doing
um there's so many people that seem to
be like afraid of taking on
difficult texts so they avoid seneca and
they avoid
cicero and they avoid epictetus and they
only read marcus aurelius marcus
aurelius is at the
end of things right he is actually
you know drawing on epictetus so why not
why not go to epictetus why not go to
cicero why not go to these these other
great people i'm not knocking marcus but
he's you know uh if you have to choose
between reading seneca's letters and not
even reading any of other seneca's stuff
and reading the meditations the letters
should win every time same thing with
epictetus's discourses
all right mark has a question here uh
dystoic concepts of wisdom include both
practical or theoretical wisdom or do
they distinguish prudence
they include both um
you know and they use sophia which we
often translate as sort of like
theoretical wisdom
and uh phronesis which we often
translate as practical wisdom because
this is an aristotelian distinction they
often use these uh synonymously as does
by the way plato
there is no you know absolute radical
distinction as we find in aristotle and
it doesn't even really hold up that well
in aristotle um
you know the the account of sophia in
nica mccann ethics book six is kind of
incoherent
um
but
in any case yeah the the use of our our
minds as both uh practical and
theoretical uh aspects to it
um
just skipped a little bit uh there was a
nice remark here
that i wanted to come to
okay so jordan says thought is work
thought is labor yes
thinking
is
work that requires courage the aspects
of it that we call like you know uh
endurance
and uh you know
overcoming your fears uh is is important
but also perseverance right you have to
keep working at it and
great works you know great literature
philosophy really anything worth
studying you have to apply yourself
you're not going to get it immediately
or if you do
you're probably getting the wrong thing
because it takes it takes work right
so
all right um
sergio says i think theoretical wisdom
is part of logic which they studied but
i don't know if it counts as the
cardinal version
the virtue of wisdom of hernansis it
absolutely does
you can't do logic without developing
phronesis for the stoics
logic ethics and physics three different
areas
all interfused again too and we know
very little of the stoic logic and
physics by the way compared to the stoic
ethics
in part because you know what we do have
is pretty fragmentary so anybody i'm
gonna put in a little rant here anybody
who's claiming oh you have to study the
stoic physics and all the ethics is
based on that they're full of crap they
they don't know what they're talking
about and they're being very dogmatic
and doctrinaire about stuff that we
don't we just simply don't have enough
texts about you know
um you can study the stoic ethics
without going too far into the stoic
physics what we do possess of it and
logic fits into that as well uh mark uh
says um i'm not sure if you mentioned
and i missed it but are there any stokes
who discussed piety as a virtue
um definitely i mean we mentioned that
that it fits in there in um these
discussions about justice
piety is part of that epictetus there's
a lot of discussions about how we ought
to orient ourselves towards god
and understand god and and what the
implications are for us and other human
beings like for example slaves right
slaves are
also
sons and daughters of god or they have
that that bit of the divine in them
seneca also talks about this as well so
piety
is is something that is robustly
explored i would say now that granted
the stoic god is not the god of uh you
know
what we often call traditional theism
and by that we mean these monotheistic
religions like judaism and christianity
and islam um where you have a
transcendent god you know who's to some
degree outside of the universe precedes
the universe acts imminently within it
you can pray to them stoics aren't big
on prayer or anything like that
but how can you be pious then well you
know try to act like god don't be a
prick to people you know be the opposite
of that be be good to people right
um
now mark also says it's something i wish
aristotle wrote more about
and you know aristotle
does talk about
he doesn't talk about the piety much he
talks about you know um
god is you know the final end drawing
other things in
um there's also like lower case g gods
the stoics also have that idea as well
but we don't have that much of their
cosmology
and it's kind of hard to relate to
anyway
sergio what makes the stoics change some
things from the original conception of
plato's cardinal virtues
they have a different anthropology they
have different preoccupations they they
you know it's there's no one single
thing
um and as a matter of fact you know the
stoics just like the plaintiffs just
like the aristotelians
they are traditions
that have um a lot of development going
on in them you know if you read plato
and then you read plutarch a middle
platonist you're going to see some
serious advances being made beyond just
plato
and then go to platinus a neoplatonist
right or even look at simplicius
commentary on epictetus's uh end
caridian a neoplatonus reading a stoic
work and you're going to see further and
further development going on
same thing with the aristotelian
tradition same thing with the stoic
tradition zeno did not say everything
that needed to be said at the very start
and then the other stoics just kind of
mumbled along for you know uh
500 600 odd years no they kept on
rethinking stuff and
reworking it and adding to it and
this is the way that that
legitimate traditions and philosophy
actually function so
eric what makes the virtues desirable i
don't know do you not want to be wise or
just or courageous or temperate it's
kind of a no-brainer isn't it you know
there isn't a beyond the virtues to make
them desirable um these are the sort of
things that if you want to actually have
a good life you need to have and you
probably want other people to have so
they're not pricks to you too right or
burdens upon you and they can do their
own their own things
um
i mean i'm being a little facetious here
but there there's there's something
actually wrong with the the way the
question is set up it it um it betrays a
kind of uh you could call it category
mistake right
the virtuous life is the good life for
the stoics and so we need the virtues
this is a really basic thing for virtue
ethics something that we find again in
the platonist and the aristotelian and
the stoic and even the epicureans
think that you need virtues now for them
they're instrumental right you need
prudence so you don't do stupid stupid
stuff that makes your life less pleasant
you need justice so you're not going to
get thrown in jail you need courage so
you can actually say no to some
pleasures and and thereby say yes to
more but they're kind of outliers most
virtue ethicists
view the virtues
as sort of fundamentally basic and
as traits that are admirable and traits
that over time are going to make us uh
happy you know
all right uh zack art is there a formal
practice of virtues in stoicism of
virtues and the way that buddhist
practice mindfulness and seated
meditation
well i mean
some buddhists practice mindfulness and
seated meditation some practice it as
they're doing work i mean that that's
one option in uh chan or zen buddhism
um and mindfulness is is a kind of empty
thing unless you add in all the other
you know sort of things that go along
with it it's just preparatory to
um ethical disciplines
and um you know visualization and you
know if you're doing pure land buddhism
you know chanting and stuff like that so
i would say you don't really compare
those they're not they're not the same
is there a formal practice
um
i don't think that stoicism has a
formal practice of the virtues the idea
is get into situations and figure out
what the hell you need to do and you can
tie this in with like negative
visualization i mean when uh epictetus
says whatever situation you get into
this in the end caridian look within
yourself and figure out what you need to
deal with it and then he talks about
virtues doesn't he you see a attractive
body what do you need temperance right
um
so you know there's there's you could
say it's formalizable but there's no one
single thing that like cuts across
everything
um
the way that say meditation would right
not that you couldn't meditate on the
virtues
um khalid says conscious awareness of
the stoic virtue seems to be a crucial
part of practicing stoicism
but i wonder if one can be an incidental
stoic i don't know what an incidental
stoic would be um
but you know i'll put it to you this way
the more that you're making these
central uh from the stoic perspective
the better off you're going to be right
and these take a development i mean the
stoics this is a separate topic that
we'll get into it another time the
stoics have this this point of view
that's really paradoxical that like
either you're virtuous or you're vicious
there's nothing in between
and i think that is just an idea that
it really it renders the ethics
incoherent
um and you notice that seneca and cicero
and even epictetus don't really buy this
uh and those are you know pretty
important heavy hitters so the evidence
is if they don't buy it we don't
actually have to buy it too
um
but
you know
so that you can say there's a continuum
right if you're only like
reading about this
once in a while and you're not actually
trying to practice the virtues and
you're not engaging in some
self-scrutiny oh was i virtuous in that
situation or was i being vicious or
somewhere in between you're probably not
going to make much progress and then you
can say well why are you doing it
why why why talk about being an
incidental stoic just live your life you
don't have to clutter it up with you
know adding a few life hacks or anything
if you if you really just want to like
um
you know
enjoy yourself and not think about stuff
or you know be an epicurean then right
or
if you
really just want to study things you
don't want to do a lot of practical
application you know go go dilite that
that sort of thing over there and you
know chat with people on twitter about
it you know
i kind of think with stoicism as with
any other intentional way of life
you got to put something into it if you
want to get anything out of it right
so
all right um
mark are there any classically informed
contemporary stoic thinkers you would
recommend any texts in particular
yeah there's a whole bunch i mean if you
want stuff that's challenging you could
you know really look at lawrence
becker's a new stoicism but that is a
quite a very challenging work
um you know a lot of the people that
we've had as as speakers at stoicon
over the years are really well
worth reading margaret graver's book on
stoicism and emotion is is just an
amazing piece uh super well researched
and you notice that she is actually one
of the translators that's her name right
there right
of seneca's letters in the university of
chicago edition you also notice anthony
long there too he's got a lot of great
books john sellers
a lot of great works on on stoicism
there's more popular stuff as well like
massimo pigliucci's how to be a stoic
donald robertson how to be a roman
emperor stoicism and cbt
um
tim labon
another member of the modern stoicism
team you notice that a lot of these
people are in the organization modern
stoicism uh tim labon has some good
stuff um
there's also i i would i'd be leery
there's a lot of like
not good stuff
out there uh because people jumped on
the stoic bandwagon and then wrote books
that were kind of
not well informed or schlocky or
basically just doing life hack stuff
i've done a few reviews of them so you
want to be a little bit careful about
that right and again how do you know
that any of these are any good you look
at the original text and see what what
the original texts have to say
right
mark says uh i recommend students try
keeping a journal like marcus aurelius
for a week as a type of esthesis
practicing personal reflection
this is a big thing yeah or it could be
like um doing the practice that seneca
recommends which he took from the
pythagoreans you know at night
do an examination of conscience now
that's a christian way of talking about
it uh because the christians did similar
things a lot a lot of christian
practices actually you know originated
with the plaintiffs or the stoics or or
the epicureans um
and uh you know like running over the
day and being like did i screw up man
how did i go off how did i lose my
temper with this person right and you
think about it that is that is often
yeah very very helpful right
um philip does the notion of pro-racists
have a place within the stoic system of
ethics yeah big place uh from epictetus
onward right it's not really discussed
in
seneca although seneca does have
volontas which is covering similar
ground um
it's not it's not playing a big role in
marcus aurelius and interestingly the
summaries of stoic ethics don't really
talk about it because
until epic titus picks it up and makes
it absolutely central to his his work
his version of stoicism
it's more of an aristotelian
uh term aristotle uses it in the nick of
mccain ethics as a matter of fact my uh
collaborator and and fellow editor of
stoicism today harold covley and i
have done a lot of work on uh pro-erasis
in the stoic
in the aristotelian and in later
platonist traditions including a
presentation
just down the road at marquette
university
on um pro-erasis
and its development in aristotle uh
epictetus alexander vaphredesius and
then simplicia so yeah it's an important
notion pro-racist means something like
faculty of choice
epictetus makes it the center of what
you are so it's basically the same thing
as the hegemonic one the ruling part
which is also the rational part so
there's this again interfusion in
epictetus
of pro-erasus
and these these other things that are
viewed as the most central part of our
self right
um
mark said i was thinking recently about
how many people want to denounce the
good as tyranny and the lack of justice
this betrays i feel mcintyre was right
we need the virtues to moderate our
practices and i think stoicism
contributes to developing that
yeah
a lot of people are very mixed up about
the good and that's i mean the good news
is that's always been the case for human
beings the bad news is that's always
been the case for human beings and this
is what moral theory
and practice helps to work out and
you're not going to like change the
whole world by practicing stoicism any
more than you will with any other
intentional way of life but you can work
on the part of the world that's messed
up that's you and the things that you
can influence around you and you can
make them better and the virtues are
needed for that now it's interesting you
bring up mcintyre because anthony long
has this wonderful wonderful piece which
can be found in his book stoic studies
but you can also find it in other places
where he criticized mcintyre's after
virtue for two things
one was getting stoicism wrong and he's
right about that other people have
pointed out that mcintyre
didn't get get stoicism right any more
than he got you know he got some things
right and he got some things wrong
viewing it as sort of protoconism is
just a form of deontology and not a form
of virtue ethics that's that's incorrect
right
um
long also pointed out that exactly the
sort of
neo-aristotelian community
that mcintyre is is suggesting in after
virtue
is being provided by a rival
tradition stoicism in the present right
and that's a really great thing to point
out i would also say that neoplatonism
or middle to neoplatonism offers us a
similar possibility as well
so
you know it's really uh it's really
quite good um what what long has to say
about that i don't know if mcintyre ever
did respond to that
eric sierra asks what do you think of
william irvine's books they're okay you
know um
i i think that different people have
different emphases
um i don't
think you know for one thing i don't
think we need to have a trichotomy of
control i've written about this
elsewhere you know
epictetus already has enough robust
resources for articulating the so-called
dichotomy of control a lot better
um
you know irvine um
i'll just put it to you this way i've
met him i've interacted with him
i think his books are you know good um
they're not my go-to and and i don't
take him
as somebody who's for me like a major
interlocutor but that's not anything
against him you you can only like engage
with so many people right so
all right uh any other questions or
comments that people have we've got
about five minutes left
a lot of good ones here
like i said we'll we'll continue doing
these monthly
uh and if people really get into it
maybe we'll do it more than monthly
right
um bottom head what about emerson
emerson's not a stoic emerson is a
transcendentalist so i don't know what
the what about means
um the the you know the
transcendentalist read the stoics
sometimes got him right sometimes got
him wrong it was very common in 19th and
20th century
philosophy and culture you know kind of
wild widely to get the stoics kind of
half right half wrong
until people started looking more
closely at stoicism
emerson is an interesting thinker i
think you know the transcendentalists
are well worth reading
very important part of american
philosophy they show you that american
philosophy is not all pragmatism
not that there's anything wrong with
pragmatism either i like i like uh james
and royce and purse not as big on dewey
uh went to southern illinois university
and actually worked at the dewey center
so we had dewey kind of shoved down our
throats and uh
i'm not quite as big on him but you know
they fit into that that spectrum any
other any other questions comments
people
want to bring up
oh okay mark says a fun question for you
what piece of faux stoicism false
stoicism you've come across peeved you
off the most
you've mentioned there's some strange
popular depictions of stoicism floating
about
um
yeah you know
i would say it's less a one single thing
part of what i really
dislike
and i think rightly so
and by the way you can be stoic and
dislike things um you you can you can
condemn things as a stoic you can say
this is garbage you can you can use
language like calling somebody an
[ __ ] if they actually are objectively
an [ __ ]
i would say the notion that stoicism can
be summarized as life hacks is probably
the most poisonous idea out there
because it you know it's it's ready made
for an internet generation where
listicles are the thing
and
a lot of it shows the opposite of wisdom
folly right a vice
and i think that some of it also shows
the opposite of courage cowardice
it takes courage to actually do the work
to read the text and then write about it
and face the fact that you're not going
to get as many views or you know
good responses right uh as somebody who
just puts you know copies a few things
and puts together some fake quotes and
stuff like that into a video
um that takes some you know some
stick-to-itiveness to use one of my my
old teachers things to talk about
fortitude
um and i would say that that's that's
sort of at the the core of it the notion
that you can cheat you can you can get
away with doing without doing the work
and still reap the rewards that's that's
a bad thing to do for it's a bad thing
for the people who are doing it for
themselves right because they're not
developing as human beings it's a bad
thing to put out there as a model
for other people and it crowds out the
good work that so many people
are doing on stoicism
and it makes it more difficult for
people who are genuinely seeking to find
the good stuff right
so
yeah mark says as a stoic you should
hopefully dislike vice at least i mean
yeah and you can dislike it in a
measured way you don't have to say oh
this is the most terrible thing ever
that's kind of silly right but you can
recognize it as a as a bad right as as
something evil as stemming from vice
right so
all right bottom head says i was
thinking of emerson's line greatness is
the perception that virtue is enough
sure i mean that's not necessarily uh
unique to stoics right um
an aristotelian a platoonist can say
that as well
um lots of lots of people who are
friends of virtue can say that it's not
it's not a purely stoic matter
um all right so it's one o'clock i've
got to get to some other work uh thanks
to everybody
for joining me for this and we'll
definitely schedule another one of these
for next month if there's enough
interest maybe we can do them more
regularly than that there's i mean it's
almost inexhaustible the number of
concepts that we can explore even with
virtue there's a lot of stuff we haven't
really
gone into here so
everybody's saying thanks you're very
welcome and i will see
everybody else
down the line somewhere else